hi everyone this is researcher miller
coming at you with a slightly different
lecture today we're not going to be
studying an SCP more we're going to be
studying the pronunciation of a word
that you will all no doubt seen in the
title of this lecture this has became a
very very annoying part of my lecture
series sometimes halfway through my
lectures shouting out it's not
pronounced quatre it's it's actually
keator you you realize you're saying it
wrong
dr. Miller right almost every lecture I
do now what's funny about this is that
they're half right I am pronouncing it
wrong there's no doubt about that but
but so are they those people are saying
it wrong as well they've clearly done no
research whereas I have so let's do some
research right now okay we're going to
consult rabbi Gail Nord because it's a
Hebrew word I think it's only fair that
we consult a rabbi on this Gail educate
us how do you say that word the highest
sorry Gail lied I didn't quite didn't
quite hear you there could you repeat
that please oh it's pronounced cat hair
I guess all you people saying
Keter have some quite large chunks of
egg on your face don't you yeah again
this slightly irritated tone isn't aimed
at anyone that says the word keator or
Keter
it's aimed at those people that are
smart asses and think they know even
when they haven't done any research that
clearly haven't or else they would have
phrased it in a different way
yeah I just need to get this off my
chest everyone thank you all for
listening if indeed you still are and
you're all dismissed goodbye
I would like to give a special thank you
to Andre bishop desmond Hoskins and get
suburi thank you all very much for your
support
it's greatly appreciated if you would
like a special thank you at the end of
each of my videos and some other cool
stuff as well go to patreon.com/scishow
you